[Musik]
[Applaus]
fast jeder zweite junge Mensch in der
Schweiz ist tätowiert
[Musik]
Tattoos haben den Sprung aus der
Schmuddelecke in den Mainstream längst
geschafft
ob Influenza
Musiker Sportlerinnen mit einem Tattoo
unterstreichen sie ihre Persönlichkeit
und Individualität
die wenigsten denken dabei an
gesundheitliche Risiken
und manche können nicht genug davon
kriegen
[Musik]
Dominik Dietrich macht sich bereit um
heute ein weiteres Tattoo auf seinen
Körper stechen zu lassen
ein Gesamtkunstwerk in das er bisher
mehr als 200 schmerzvolle Stunden und
über 130.000 Franken investiert hat
und es ist noch lange nicht fertig
[Musik]
okay
und
ja
hast am Anfang habe
[Musik]
und das Hanni ja hat auch sehr schön
gefunden dass das ein wichtiger Teil ist
und zu dem Körper gehört
[Musik]
Dominik arbeitet bei der Gewerkschaft
sündy komm und seinen bunten Körper
sieht er auch als politisches Statement
[Musik]
St Gallen klappt habe eine politisch
sehr aktiv gesehen und hat in der
Nationalrat kandidiert aber dazu mal im
2015 das gesehen und haben ich würde
nie so sehr
machen dass er egal ob man schwarz weiß
oder sind alles Menschen und alle gleich
und dementsprechend
Auftritte natürlich
sprechen viele Menschen hat zum
Überlegen und und so sämtliche ist das
Hotel oder das wird sich Gedanken über
die Themen machen
und noch eine Leidenschaft verdient ein
Tattoo
ja ich bin natürlich schon immer Knight
Rider und Baywatch Banksy und
dementsprechend auch von David
Hasselhoff und den Resultat tatsächlich
Ferien und dann sehen wir morgen vorher
vom David Hasselhoff Tätowieren
unverteiler auf der Stelle und den hat
sich denn noch ein paar Jahre später
tatsächlich
kennenlerne und hat ihn wirklich die
Leber beim ersten Treffen
unverteiligte zeigen das wäre wirklich
speziell so schnell schnell normal dass
David Hasselhoff Tattoo stechen das
Treffen tatsächlich
dementsprechend auch unterschrieben und
die hatten das können den Tag später den
nachsteu
[Musik]
die Entdeckung Polynesiens durch den
Seefahrer James Cook im 18 Jahrhundert
und die Verschleppung von edlen Wilden
die mit merkwürdigen Zeichen und Bildern
bemalt waren stießen in Europa auf ein
staunendes Publikum
tatau nannten die Polynesia ihre
Körperkunst und das tatau entwickelte
sich später das Wort Tattoo
die Zeichen welche eine tiefe Symbolik
haben wurden in Polynesien oder wie hier
in sumata mit einem einfachen Holzstück
und einem spitz zugefeilten Knochen
tätowiert
sie zeigen die Stammes Zugehörigkeit und
dienen als Schutz vor Krankheiten oder
bösen Geistern
die Kraft und Symbolik die von
traditionellen Tattoos ausgehen
faszinieren auch an die Stiegler
vor einiger Zeit ließ er sich bereits
ein samoanisches Stammes Tattoo auf Arm
und schulterstechen allerdings mit der
Tätowiermaschine
nun spielt er mit dem Gedanken sich ein
Tattoo auf traditionelle samoanische Art
klopfen zu lassen dass es ein
schmerzhaftes Unterfangen ist weiß er
dennoch ist er fest entschlossen es zu
wagen
mein Engel
gestoßen in Freiburg und sehr stark
Homepage
ganze kreative Persönlichkeit oder wo
nicht faulig ist sondern das macht wo er
erzählt und nicht das macht wo du immer
gesagt
noch der traditionellen Ort also
im Tattoostudio in Freiburg im Breisgau
erwartet ihn thomasi sudu Apple
erst im persönlichen Gespräch entstehen
die Muster für das tatau
ungefähr einfach nicht dass es bist
einfach im Zustand wo muss
Grundkonzept steht ist immer wichtig
dass der Flausch geht und Energie
von dem ganzen Gerücht
können wir gleich loslegen
genau so
das kann ich noch nie zuordnen aber er
Vertrauen und die Wünsche
[Musik]
seinen deutschen Namen hat Tomasi vor
langer Zeit abgelegt damals als er auf
einer Weltreise in Samoa hängen blieb
und seine Leidenschaft für das
traditionelle tatau entdeckte
er lernte die Familie suluire kennen
viele Meister der samoanischen
Tätowierkunst stammen aus dieser Familie
wie ein Sohn wurde er von der
Gemeinschaft aufgenommen und in die
Geheimnisse des Handwerks eingeführt
[Musik]
dieses Wissen über die rituellen Regeln
die Technik aber vor allem über die
spirituelle Bedeutung der Symbole wird
von Generation zu Generation
weitergegeben
den tathaus sind für samoana weit mehr
als bloßer Körperschmuck die
Tätowierungen zeigen Status und Herkunft
sie sollen Kraft spenden und sogar die
Lebensgeschichte des Trägers
beeinflussen können
auch die Herstellung der traditionellen
Werkzeuge muss ein Tätowierer
beherrschen
[Musik]
ich darf ja eigentlich nicht lustig sein
ja ich müsste Logo im großen schwarze
konkurrog total strengst Gesicht machen
bin ich aber leider nicht ich bin erste
der lustige weil ich versuche dann halt
mal Leute so ein bisschen abzuholen ja
und manchmal ein bisschen Witze und so
das fällt dann im Kunde einfach weil wir
jetzt keine samura die hier mit der
Ukulele und so bitte wäre was eigentlich
schön wäre aber
[Musik]
die
ältesten Tattoos die an einem Menschen
entdeckt wurden sind etwa 5.400 Jahre
alt
rund 60 Tätowierungen ziehen den Körper
von Ötzi
seine Tattoos wurden nicht gestochen
sondern in die Haut geritzt
da sich die Zeichen auf Akupunktur
Stellen befinden vermuten
Wissenschaftler dass sie aus
medizinischen Gründen zur
Schmerzlinderung angebracht wurden
man geht davon aus dass sich die
Methoden des Tätowierens bei
verschiedenen Völkern der Erde
selbstständig und unabhängig voneinander
entwickelt haben
im Mittelalter verbreiteten sich in
Europa christlich religiöse Motive
bis 1890 wurden in Bosnien katholische
Mädchen tätowiert um einen Übertritt zum
Islam zu verhindern
später waren es vor allem Matrosen
kriminelle oder Rocker die ihre
Gesinnung oder Zugehörigkeit unter die
Haut stechen ließen entsprechend
anrüchig war der Ruf von tätowierten
diese Vorurteile spürte auch die Ski
also 1974 das erste Tattoo-Studio der
Schweiz in Rheineck im Kanton St Gallen
eröffnete
das Schweizer Fernsehen berichtete ein
paar Jahre später darüber die Meinung
schien allerdings bereits gemacht zu
sein
Studie sind die tätowierfreudigen
meistens burschten aus brühfly und
Soziales
er unterscheidet zwischen zwei
verschiedene Tätowierer der einzige hat
exhibitionistische zügung
[Musik]
eine Legende war Herbert Hofmann der
älteste aktive Tätowierer Europas
[Musik]
mein Schlagwort ist immer das wenn ich
mich ausziehen wenn ich immer noch
angezogen also so ganz nackt fühl ich
mich nie
angefangen hat er in einem Studio auf
der Reeperbahn in Hamburg
die letzten 20 Jahre lebte und
tätowierte er in Heiden im Kanton
Appenzell
meine erste Tätowierung war alles noch
mit handnadeln gestochen und weil es
damals noch keine Farben gab war das
alles in schwarz gemacht halten und so
habe ich mir das dann auch im machen
lassen sofort als ich aus der
sowjetischen Kriegsgefangenschaft wieder
zurück war
im Sitzen ist es doch gemütlicher als im
Stehen ne
über 50.000 Motive hat er in seinen 90
Jahren gestochen
noch im hohen Alter besuchen ihn Fans
aus der ganzen Welt
als ich damals angefangen habe und dass
Tätowieren ja noch so in Argen lag und
so gerichtet war da habe ich mir immer
gesagt du musst etwas dafür tun dass die
Tätowierung wieder gesellschaftsfähig
wird und diese Saat ist aufgegangen und
ich habe sogar sehr große Freude daran
dass ich deswegen bestätigt für finde
wofür ich mich damals eingesetzt habe
die 1980er Jahre lösten einen wahren
tattoo-boom aus aus dem Gangster Image
wurde ein Modetrend an dem auch immer
mehr Frauen Gefallen fanden
[Musik]
sowohl professionelle wie auch
hobby-tätowierer überschwemmten den
Markt Geräte für den Heimgebrauch
konnten einfacher erworben werden
gefährliche Pigmentfarben oder
Hygienevorschriften waren kaum ein Thema
heute versuchen über 700 meist kleinere
Studios von der Tätowierkunst zu leben
die größte Konkurrenz kommt dabei aus
Zürich
Geschäftsführerin carda ilardo hat vor
20 Jahren ebenfalls mit einem kleinen
Studio in Zürich angefangen doch heute
besitzt und führt die zweifache Mutter
das größte Tattoo und Piercing Imperium
der Schweiz
fürs Tätowieren bleibt ihr keine Zeit
mehr denn mittlerweile arbeiten über 50
Angestellte für Sie
[Musik]
alles angefangen hat dann mit 16
und
mit Andy sagt seine
Augen
Vision von euch sie versuchen das ganze
so aus dem Mustern
gefunden das hat extrem Potenzial aber
sie hat einfach ja vielleicht falsch
vermarktet oder falsche Ecke mir hat
eigentlich die Idee gefallen dass jeder
trage oder das Piercing vertragen
und das ist doch wieder Initiative
Gedanken sind
[Musik]
und diesen Gedanken hat sie mitten in
der Stadt Zürich am bester Lage
umgesetzt mit erst 27 Jahren eröffnete
sie 2012 auf drei Etagen ein Tattoo und
piercing-geschäft an der Löwenstraße ein
hipper-event und Sinnbild für den Wandel
in der tattoos-szene
[Musik]
plötzlich wurden Tattoos zum boomenden
Millionen business
Straße
und ähm ich kann bis zum heutigen
geschaffen und ja habe ich natürlich
[Musik]
spezialisieren in der Spezialisierung
werden die ein bestimmtes Spiel und dass
ich vorhin eine Micro lesen und da ist
immer spezialisiert
[Musik]
in der Schweiz gibt es keine offizielle
Tätowierer Ausbildung das Wissen wird
innerhalb der Branche weitergegeben
kümmert sich sie mir um die aus und
Weiterbildung der new talents
[Musik]
zum ofenhütigen Level wirklich
professionell können als Tattoo
artistalter ist der Weg sicher über das
Studio das mit der lernt und
professionell begleitet wird alles
andere für die High use wird sich als
sehr schwer gestalten oder wird vor
allem Bildungslücken auf das wird dann
zwar viel vielleicht auf das andere
Prozess das ganze hygienes wird
vielleicht nachlässig darum
definitiv viel zu Tags dass man sich mit
professionelle Hand begibt vom nette
Zuschauern und zum Professor ich glaube
so eine Entwicklung hör auf weil sie
Branche entwickelt sich ständig weiter
es geht ständig neue Techniker neue
Materialien halt immer wieder das Level
Ufern und darum muss eigentlich immer am
Ball bleiben
aber zumal das
ist sicher 1 bis 3 Jahre damit bist
und neben dem Wissen braucht es vor
allem auch künstlerisches Talent
[Musik]
eine Geschichte die nun auch unter die
Haut geht
[Musik]
zwischen Hofer und Angst und das muss
jetzt einfach
abgeschlossen hat
so mangeln
[Musik]
emotional
ja es verbindet ist nur noch mehr sagen
[Musik]
spezialisiert auf Comic Tätowierungen
aber farbig bunt und komme geschmissen
steckerpferd
[Musik]
dieses Pferd ist in Gefahr denn die EU
verbietet seit dem 1 Januar 2022 die
meisten Tattoo-Farben
vor 20 Jahren kamen Pigmentfarben in
Verruf da oft sogenannte azo Farben
verwendet wurden die auch im Autolack
enthalten sind
sie sollen krebserregend sein
Langzeitstudien gibt es noch nicht aber
die Schweiz könnte schon bald ein
ähnliches Verbot wie die EU aussprechen
oder Abwege wie so organisieren
aber aus wies ist schon alle die Kritik
gestanden
dass sie mehrere spielbaren
Gesetzgebung momentan hat
so den
ist Motiv wenn deine sitzt dann ist
schön gestochene Tattoos
[Musik]
unsere Haut besteht aus drei Schichten
die Oberhaut die Lederhaut und die
Unterhaut
die große Kunst des Tätowierens ist die
richtige Hautschicht zu treffen das ist
Millimeterarbeit
denn geht die Farbe nur in die Oberhaut
verschwindet das Tattoo bereits nach ein
paar Wochen
sticht der Tätowierer zu tief trifft die
Nadel auf die gut durchblutete Unterhaut
neben zusätzlichen Schmerzen verfließen
die Farben und das Bild hat keine klaren
Konturen
ein erfahrener Tätowierer sticht die
Nadel ein bis zwei Millimeter in die
Lederhaut dort wird die Farbe von
Fresszellen umschlossen und eingelagert
im Laufe der Zeit wird etwa ein Drittel
der Farbe vom Körper abgebaut
in Brunnen im Kanton Schwyz befindet
sich die Praxis von Bettina Schlagenhauf
die Dermatologin sieht bei ihrer Arbeit
immer wieder Probleme die nach einer
Tätowierung auftreten
[Musik]
die meisten Probleme treten eigentlich
unmittelbar nach dem Tätowieren auf es
kann zu verzögerter Wundheilung kommen
Infektionen direkt durch die Einstiche
durch Eindringen von Bakterien oder die
Fremdkörper die da ja in die Haut
gebracht werden das kann zu brennen zu
auch durchaus Schwellungen Blasen
Krustenbildung führen was in der Regel
wenn gut behandelt wieder abheilt aber
manchmal wenn es dumm läuft einmal
Narben hinterlassen können
zudem kommt wenn man sehr viel Farbe in
der Haut hat insbesondere dunkle Farben
schwarz Farben wenn man sich damit an
die Sonne begibt
die werden heiß es gibt schreckliche
sogenannte fototoxische Reaktionen da
reagiert einfach die Haut dann mit
Schwellungen Rötungen und und auch
Schmerzen
Sonnenbäder verändern die Farben sie
bringen sie einerseits schneller zum
ablassen
andererseits entstehen wieder
Abbauprodukte die potenziell gefährlich
sein könnten oder auch einfach Allergien
auslösen können
man vermutet dass wir deswegen in
unserer Praxis immer wieder Leute mit
Tattoos sehen die noch nach Monaten bis
Jahren plötzlich Knotenbildungen in den
Tattoos bekommen und das muss behandelt
werden
eigentlich soll ja der Tätowierer keine
Fehler machen man Mitarbeiter ist
allerdings doch das Missgeschick
passiert als er mir diesen Stern hier
hat tätowiert hatte er erst die oberen
Zacken richtig gemacht und dann hat er
auf der anderen Seite angefangen und
dabei eben die Seiten verwechselt und
dann war es nicht mehr zu reparieren
heute würde Herbert Hoffmann vielleicht
in eine
tattooentfernungspraxis gehen
Geschäftsführer peter Steiner behandelt
Michel food der bereits zu vierten
Laserbehandlung in die Praxis kommt
[Musik]
am Computer okay
Tattoo wird mit jeder Behandlung
schwächer
ob es ganz verschwindet hängt auch von
der Farbe ab
[Musik]
das
Tattoo Gültigkeit verliert im Info
entweder findet die Identifikation mit
mitgenommen
okay dann würden wir starten
und wenn tut genug
starten wenn du irgendwie während der
Laserung
ganz einfach mir hat versucht das
über eine Operation halt wir macht
nichts Vision und
schnitzelidem sind es geht so genau
water injecting wo man eigentlich das
tut eröffnet wird und dann eigentlich
vor unser spüren sind
dann geht's
Variante mit chemischen Peeling wo man
in dem Sinn dort mit mit syrischer und
die Syrien entsprechend unter tutti
bringen und bitte chemische Reaktion
erzeugt und so eigentlich versucht zu
entfernen ist immer mit Narbe verbunden
in dem sinnig ist definitiv die sanft
ist die Methode zum Essen entfernen
Ziel vom Laser schlussendlich ist dass
mir die Farbe während zertrümmere oder
so dass eigentlich System also wir sind
Körper dann im Stand ist mit gewissen
Zellen und nachher die
Farb transportieren schwarze Tattoos
sind grundsätzlich am besten zum
behandeln
[Musik]
grundsätzlich muss sich der Hund bewusst
sieht dass sind Ferne von meiner Tattoo
ein Vielfaches meistens kostet als
machen selber im Gegensatz zum Stacheln
[Musik]
ein samoanischer Tätowierer braucht beim
traditionellen klopfen Assistenten
welche die Haut richtig spannen eine
Aufgabe die viel Fingerspitzengefühl und
Erfahrung braucht
wenn ich mich bewegt
sind normal ist es drei Schlag aber
Derschlag öffnet der zweite Schlag
bringt Pigment ein und der drittes sitzt
praktisch an der Platz normalerweise
aber das ist eigentlich sehr kann ich
nicht klassisch sagen aber tut immer
anders reagiert jeder anders Werkzeug
jeder hat eine andere Rhythmus
eigentlich für sich ja also ran ich habe
auch noch verschiedene Stück das Lagern
und andere
natürlich
und vor allem was er für dich eins
machen bzw komme ich ja erst wenn der
Techniker kennst mich erstmal dass du
weißt was du durch und dann weiß ich
noch lange was dadurch bist du dann
nicht mal die eigene Stille noch nicht
das ist schlimmer hatte eigentlich
zehn Jahre jetzt mal los dass du
bisschen was los ist
[Gelächter]
und natürlich im Bälle Geschwindigkeit
und wir am besten
die Haut ist stretchen brauchten mal
weniger mal mehr das ist schon natürlich
ganz Gefühl quasi
dass du haben muss ich habe bisschen
schwierig das ist komplett anders wie
mit Maschine zu tätowieren und
traditionell und dadurch dass er Leute
davon brauchen dann habe ich ihm
angeboten einfach dass ich das lernen
das normale tätowiere wenn Sie das
nachher macht dann kann mit der Muster
arbeiten und weiß was sie tut und Weise
mehr war wahrscheinlich wie die meiste
ja aber eine Frau ist ja normalerweise
Tabuthema mit der Instrumente
in samura für diesen monatliche Kultur
und dementsprechend richtig mich hallo
nach der Regel der Familie
da gibt's halt recht wenigen Verständnis
aber was wirklich Europäer angeht im
tätowiererbereich ja die jetzt einfach
ihren Job machen als Dienstleister und
jetzt jemand wie mich höre der hat er
nicht hatte ja aber es darf sich ja
jeder ganz normal eine überzeugen drüber
fliegen und dann schauen wir
was die Sache ist ja und ähm bei mir hat
das noch relativ bequem sage ich
so ja sie kann es das Spannen und kann
hier mit der Hand und entspanne helfen
und geht jetzt mit ins bleiwunder nein
drück auf deine Hand hier die bleibt
und du dumme Hunde
du gehörst klopfen
und die ganzen psychischen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und die ganze Kreativität und auch
Individualität
sehr niedriger und ja mache besonders
die Fantasy Basel ist für einen Cartoon
und Fantasy-Fan wie Dominik ein Paradies
und eine wichtige Inspirationsquelle
zudem hat er einen weiteren Termin bei
seinem Haus Tätowierer es gibt einiges
zu tun er möchte vorwärts machen solange
die Pigmentfarben in der Schweiz noch
erlaubt sind
[Musik]
ich von 1897
zwei elektromagnetische
120 Jahren
[Musik]
wie in Erinnerung
mit dem Namen von ihm zweiter Sohn und
Geburtsdatum vor ihm dafür für mich
Freiheit aus der Asche natürlich kommt
er heraus und ich wurde ziemlich oft
gehänselt und sich endlich mal in meinem
Leben leben kann und nicht so wie die
anderen sich das vorstellen das bedeutet
eigentlich
mega cool da will also heiß finde
eigentlich die Tür na jetzt dürfen das
Kunstwerk also mit der Kunstwerk hat
oder auf dem Körper das ist Kunst und
Menge Zahnspange
also super Sach
e
[Musik]
langsam endet auch an die stieglers
Tortur so reine Richtung Finale
langsam
fertig machen
mit dem Haus zusammen mit einer Frau mit
den Kindern
und ergeben und nehmen Prozess wo alle
dann in einem Haus zusammen als Einheit
sind das von außen beschützt ist
sensationell also
sicher betroffen
wenn es vorzeichnet herrscht weiß noch
nicht was Sandra Soldat wird
Strukturen das ist einfach nur eine
schwanger
[Musik]
Farbe kann zurzeit noch aus einer großen
pigmentvielfalt schöpfen dass das bald
nicht mehr möglich sein soll versteht er
nicht
[Musik]
er wurscht
und schwarz wird dass ich hoch gerade
krebserregen und er ist mir sicher da
genau
ich glaube auch
dass mir das einfach machen
wie der Gesetzgeber die gesundheitlichen
Risiken einschätzt wird die Zukunft
zeigen
ja es ist so viel Termine bei dem Johann
ich glaube noch gar nicht gemacht und es
ist eigentlich komisch als der Zufall
dass
er genau
[Musik]